Capture all your aquatic GoPro adventures
using the Seawolf underwater remote operated
vehicle.
And water the ocean on land in mid air with
these Giant Squid Hanging Planters.
Because it’s episode 53 of LÜT.
There’s nothing like cooking great food
in the great outdoors on a rock.
The Roccbox is a portable, lightweight stone
bake oven that heats up an insulated internal
stone floor.
It's perfect for roasting meat, cooking a
90 second pizza or cooking anything else in
this 500 degree rock in a box.
For a rock you can snuggle up to the living
stones pillows are the perfect pebbles.
The 100% eco-friendly stone pillows come in
many different sizes and are available in
mix color rocks and river rocks.
But unfortunately not The Rock.
Pillow.
Smell what the Flavor God is cooking with
these healthy and delicious seasonings.
The low salt, chemical free and filler free
seasonings are made fresh to order and there’s
even a VIP club to get early access to limited
specialty flavors like pizza and chocolate
donut.
Do not allow anyone to pilfer your precious
confections after attaching the Sammy Screamer
Motion Alarm.
It sounds an alarm when it’s moved and notifies
your smartphone so hang it on a backpack or
stroller to keep your stuff safe.
Save all kinds of broken stuff thanks to Sugru.
A moldable glue that feels like Play Doh but
bonds permanently to glass, metal, wood and
most plastics.
The silicone rubber is also stable at high
temperatures, waterproof, and can be shaped.
Shape up as you travel on the elliptical bicycle.
And cycle through your Instagram pics to decide
which would make the best temporary tattoo.
Picattoo allows you to pick twelve images
from your Facebook or Instagram accounts and
get them shipped to you for free as temporary
tattoos.
Infuse your tea with a yellow submarine.
But you may prefer we all live in a low-energy
ecocapsule.
The portable house fits two people and includes
a bathroom and a kitchenette.
And it has off-grid energy capabilities in
the form of a wind turbine, solar cells, and
rainwater collection.
Collect every monster eye handmade by an artist
in Italy.
The Little Shop Of Monsters features rings,
bracelets and single eyes created in acrylic
resin.
Ranging from Ghostly Eyes to Reptile Eyes.
iPad sound covers from onandoff have built-in
stereo speakers boosting the volume by up
to 400%.
Speaking of speakers Sony’s bluetooth LED
lightbulb has a speaker that can wireless
play music - successfully uniting sound and
light.
Floating light.
The rechargeable USB floating light turns
any glass into a lamp.
The bright LED last three hours which is plenty
of time to peer into the future.
Super Awesome Future Fortune cards are a new
spin on tarot cards replacing the classic
artwork with modern imagery like cat lady
and blender.
Blend chocolate and households objects by
ordering molded chocolate tool from The Chocolate
Vault.
They have all your handyman chocolate needs
including electrical sockets, spark plugs
and hack saws.
See your candle spiral after lighting the
spiral light candle.
The unique coiled wick recycles itself by
melting the wax into the center - leaving
you with a normal pillar candle to fill your
room with its warm glow.
Grow your own…hairy....uhh...
Motion simulators!
BMIgaming sells 3D, 4D, 5D, 6D, and 7D motion
simulator rides.
No only do the seats move and vibrate - they
also have air, bubbles, snowflakes, water
drops, joysticks, 3D images and stereoscopic
sound and light guns to destroy zombies.
Destroy nutshells like a colorful robot.
Just don’t drop any on your amazing 3D liquid
floor.
The decorative epoxy flooring has a 3D image
printed under a translucent layer - transforming
rooms into works of art.
Finally, work adorable figurines into your
beverage imbibing routine by adding a Fuchi-ko
on the cup.
Small toys that sit on the edge of your cup
because they are...why not?
They're really cute.
Almost as cute this fungi house backpack.
And if you’re not down with the fungi.
Get down with Chill Nye.
And as always - thanks for watching.